hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zum video ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich bin über jemanden von
euch auf ein angebot aufmerksam geworden
was ich eigentlich ganz interessant fand
und zwar habe ich mir gedacht dass ich
jetzt in zukunft wenn ich weiter so
retouren videos mache was ich schon vor
habt natürlich nicht nur es wird auch
anderen content geben das ist ganz
wichtig zu sagen habe jetzt schon ganz
oft amazon retouren videos gemacht oder
auch zalando oder irgendwann vom netto
oftmals war das auch gemischte paletten
oder gemischte ware von verschiedenen
verkaufshäusern und ich versuche jetzt
in zukunft das so zu machen dass ich so
wie heute zum beispiel euronics retouren
habe ich bestellt habe ich bin mal
gespannt oder dann schaue h&m retouren
zu bestellen was gibt es noch expert
keine ahnung irgendwie sowas und das
halt einfach mal abzuchecken und zu
schauen was so am coolsten ist oder was
überhaupt cool ist dass man sich immer
in einem video auf eine sache
fokussieren kann genau jemand von euch
hat mir dieses euronics angebot
geschickt hier sind bei euronics
retouren drin ich fand das ganze
interessant weil ich habe nur 290 euro
bezahlt und warenwert sollen über 1600
euro sein wir haben ja aber nur b und c
ware trotzdem bin ich einfach mal
gespannt ob sich das lohnt wird sagen
viele haben gar nicht lange und fangen
direkt mal an was ich aber noch ganz
kurz sagen möchte und zwar war ich
gestern für meine oma was kaufen bei
euronics wir haben ja auch ein in der
nähe und da hat mich ein mitarbeiter auf
meine retouren videos angesprochen und
ich habe ihn angefangen habt ihr auch
retouren und er hat mir keinen kontakt
gegeben und dann habe ich halt
vielleicht bald mal so richtige retouren
von einem richtigen euronics laden und
nicht über den zwischenhändler das wäre
ja auch mal ganz nice das kommt dann
eventuell man also ich freue mich und
wir packen jetzt mal aus let's go ich
überlegt mit dem rauchen aufzuhören
ich sage euch dann später bescheid wenn
ich fertig überlegt habe sowas geht wir
sind bei mir in der auspackt zentrale
ich muss sagen dass hier ist das
wundervolle paket es liegt definitiv
mehr als ein kilo das steht hier drauf
ich würde mal schätzen so 20 und
vorgestern die reihe gekommen ihr wisst
ja ich wohne ja gar nicht arbeite hier
in der ersten etage und manchmal sind
die paketboten so lieb und bringen die
pakete nicht bis nach oben sondern
stellen wir einfach unten hin und dieses
paket lag quasi komplett auf unten also
musste ich erstmal wieder zu kleben und
dann hochtragen kunden retouren
rückläufer pc-ware technik euronics
multi media mix ja das steht hinten
drauf ich habe ja schon erklärt und
gezeigt was das ist und wir schauen
einfach mal ob sich das lohnt 290 euro
habe ich bezahlt und waren wert waren ja
auf jeden fall über 1500 hoffen wir mal
dass ein schuss in den ofen wird
übrigens gerade meinen ventilatoren ich
hoffe das hört man nicht zu stark jetzt
gerade ist wahrscheinlich sehr windig
hört man halt mal mein mikro dran
manchmal frage ich mich wirklich was sie
sich denken wenn die das verpacken also
weil das hier war überhaupt nicht gut
verpackt und ja ich konnte deswegen auch
schon einmal so grob einloggen kann aber
eigentlich noch kein fazit nennen also
war schwierig also dass hier sieht auf
jeden fall so aus als wäre es von 2008
naja ich weiß nicht wir starten einfach
mal mit dem ersten produkt das ist hier
ein alarm ist es kein alarm es ist ein
arm sowie mein arm
und jetzt breakdance uni arminia da
kannst du deinen fernseher oder dem pc
bildschirm mit anpacken und den an die
wand schrauben oder wo auch immer
eigentlich sind solche dinger immer ganz
nützlich und die haben auch manchmal
wert also ich habe für meinen den ich zu
hause habe hier schaut mein fernsehen
habe ich 40 euro bezahlt dass ich den
andere wand schrauben konnte und es so
schon mal gar nicht so schlecht leute
bevor jetzt wieder welche von euch
meckern dass ich heute wieder neu
retouren auspacke woran ich ja schon
spaß habe das wisst ihr ja nächste woche
gibt es mal wieder ein anderes video und
danach die woche kommt dann die travel
video das wir glaube ich auch echt cool
da mache ich nämlich diese postleitzahl
nummer die ich letztens mal gemacht
haben europaweit mit flugzeug da freue
ich mich schon drauf ok als nächstes
haben wir hier einen war ich brauche
eigentlich meinen scanner wir haben hier
ein motherboard und zwar das h 310 cmh
dva ja das hier ist mainboard kostet im
internet leider nur 35 euro ich hatte
jetzt irgendwie mit gerechnet aber gut
ganz wenig zu machen und weiter geht's
hier ist hier etwas großes solche direkt
mit der großen sache hier weitermachen
skateboard hat mein gott es ist kein
skateboard es ist ein drucker wieso
wieso ist denn auf einer hp drucker
verpackung ein skateboard gebt euch mal
ich dachte wirklich ist werden
skateboard des sehr witzig gewesen dann
hätte ich einfach ein skateboard clowns
in druckkammern ich hatte schon mal
richtig glück mit zu druckern und zwar
an das laser drucker von samsung und die
haben einfach 600 euro gekostet ich habe
zwar nicht 604 bekommen wo ist sein
müsste so ein jahr 82 euro drucker sein
e bay karton wieso ist guck mal ebay das
ist ja richtig verrückt wieso ist das so
da komme ich jetzt gar nicht drauf klar
wartet das muss ich mal kurz hinstellen
ich hatte mal in der vergangenheit eine
zusammenarbeit mit ebay wie ähnlich das
aussieht und hat dann halt von
hintergrund seinen karton gebastelt wo
ich auch ebay drauf geschrieben habt ihr
wtf sehen einfach komplett gleich aus
und den habe ich selber gemacht und der
war hier drin das ist ja schon fast
gruselig vielleicht heißt das dass die
die mir den karton geschickt haben von
diesen noch mal vielleicht meine videos
und das war so eine versteckte botschaft
wer weiß ja habe ich ungefähr richtig
eingeordnet neu kostet 75 gebraucht habe
hier ein für 30a was haben wir denn hier
wusste ich gar nicht dass so etwas immer
noch verkauft wird wobei wirklich ich
gehe davon aus diese ware ist zwar das
ist bestimmt alles schon ein bisschen
älter naja hier haben wir einen control
taste handy da kann ich meine
drogengeschäfte mit abwickeln sagt zack
was eigentlich einen guten zustand
dinger kosten nichts mehr vielleicht 20
euro ja grüße ich wäre ja wie die
rentner auflegen
ich weiß nicht ob man die marke canon
musste ich kennen sie nicht also ich
kannte sie nicht jetzt kenne ich sie ihr
so sieht das aus leute konto okay dann
machen wir mal weiter alter und
telefonnummer
das ist schaue mir gleich an den laptop
case mit tastatur das ist ein laptop und
tastatur in schutz für sieht ja schon
fast aus als wäre das für macbook von
allergrößter könnens passen es ist
tatsächlich für macbooks ja gut damit
kann ich sogar selber was anfangen gar
nicht so verkehrt hier haben wir ein
paket und noch ein paket denke mal das
hier ist schon auf als kopfhörer
kopfhörer von jabra die marke sagt mir
bis jetzt auch noch überhaupt nichts
aber die qualität ist gar nicht so
verkehrt und die dinger leuchten
aufleuchten das heißt sie funktionieren
leider ist da schon ohrenschmalz dran
das ist natürlich nicht so geil hier
kann man es sehen sagt aber ich glaube
wir schätzen die kosten aber ein
bisschen was und das gute ist die haben
wir gleich zweimal also ich gehe davon
aus ich sehe hier auch noch mal drin
sind eins zwei und drei waren hier doch
nicht jetzt eine maus den ort ist ja gar
nicht so eine [ __ ] aus alter wer
benutzt heutzutage noch so eine maus
naja egal immerhin einmal via brief
kopfhörer alltag schaut mal hier ja
welche sind das war das ist gut das ist
gut schade ist nur dass die verpackung
fehlt also die neuesten dinger kosten
tatsächlich
179 euro und das müssten die sogar sein
wenn euch jemand foto ein das ist zwar
schon gebraucht ich weiß aber nie krieg
ich da noch für unheilig schon im ersten
drittel wieder raus ja so kann man noch
weitermachen ein headset die marke kenne
ich nicht zumindest bis jetzt nicht wir
zählen auf jeden fall die polsterung das
ist super schade deswegen kannst du dort
eigentlich nur schwierig wieder
loswerden dann haben wir hier als
nächstes für fans und tablets eine tisch
halterung kann ich persönlich nichts mit
anfangen aber gut und jetzt wird's bild
also wir haben immer noch ein bisschen
was vor uns hier ist ein kinderradio mal
gucken ob das funktioniert fällt jetzt
sagt jetzt nicht erfüllt der stecker
dass wir ganz tragisch mit usb und sim
karte aha ich habe einen wohnt kommt ein
mit dir dann bringen wir die rohre mal
zum laufen
letztmalig nachfolgendes ich verbinde
mein iphone mit dem teil und macht dann
mal ein geiles ding rein der in jedem
kinderzimmer laufen sollte das sieht
nicht gut aus ich glaube das ding ist
kaputt hallo
da geht es doch es läuft leute ich hab
so jetzt machen wir mal ob usb manchmal
hilft es einfach einmal drauf zu hauen
dann geht es an
mit dem rauchen aufzuhören
leute es geht wieder aus ich glaube das
ding ist leider voll im arsch
das hört sich gar nicht gut an das ding
ist eine richtige retour also das ist
auch eine retoure die man nicht mehr
reparieren kann über scheint okay widmen
wir uns mal wieder den wichtigen dingen
hier haben wir ein iphone 12.000 case
geil kann ich gebrauchen kennt ja mein
handy mittlerweile es ist voll am arsch
und ich war immer zu faul mir in case zu
kaufen und jetzt seht ihr hier live wie
mein handy einfach wieder gut aus ich
hab mich vollidiot ich habe jan 12 uhr
mit ihr sollen büro telefon für die
geschäftlichen geschäfts telefonate ja
in flossing agentur alexy was kann ich
für sie tun auch sie wollen ihr video
integration ja die kostet auf jeden fall
über 5000 euro wales latschau nächsten
deal vorhanden kann auch sein dass es
ein autotelefon ist hier haben wir noch
eine maus eine legendary gaming mouse
von logitech acht das headset eben war
übrigens auch meine logik jetzt fällt es
mir auf allots kennen die kostet 50 euro
ist für mich eine gaming-maus ja so
schlecht ist das gar nicht also kleiner
nachtrag noch mir ist aufgefallen in dem
paket waren halt irgendwie auch amazon
retouren das sieht man an den qr-code
ich wollte das einfach nur gesagt haben
dass ich das selber weiß nicht dass ihr
euch irgendwie wundert da waren ja auch
so kleine amazon kartons wein oder so
ganz kleine pakete wollte ich einmal
kurz zwischendurch gesagt haben eine
sd-karte 128 gigabyte geil die kann ich
ja sogar gebrauchen und hier ist
vermutlich noch eine sd-karte gründen
alter noch mal 128 gb die dinger kosten
auf 30 euro und hier lass mich raten ist
wahrscheinlich noch eine drin mit
ebenfalls 128 gb 3 sd karten sind so
gesehen wieder 90 euro ein gut sagen wir
20 usd karte ich habe mich leicht
verrechnet das waren alte preise von
damals ich habe schon lange keine stick
hat mit ok hier haben wir einen netto
okay lamin ihr gerät oder so da ist
irgendwas für drucker tonerkartusche
vielen dank habe ich schon immer gesucht
ich wusste bis heute nicht dass es so
was gibt jetzt weiß ich's und ich weiß
nicht was ich damit anfangen soll aber
ich habe heute ein drucker und der
funktioniert auch ohne tonerkartusche
machen aber kurz mit schrott weiter hier
haben wir so ein auto an knopf pineapple
dann haben wir hier noch keine ahnung
wie haben wir ganz viele dvds und cd ist
das schießt daraufhin dass die ware alle
schon ein bisschen hier haben wir noch
ein radio aha schau mal hier kenwood
radio das sieht aus als wäre das noch
ungeöffneten oder zumindest halt ja gut
zugemacht worden
heute schaut mal hier ein radio und wenn
du jetzt auch nicht gehst dann haben wir
beide problem das sieht auf jeden fall
so weit gut aus ja richtige uhrzeit ist
auf fast eingetragen erster siebter 2022
passt ein tolles radio ich glaube das
kostet auch bis 500 euro muss ich sagen
nicht sehr guter deal zu haben wir hier
130 euro also ich bin mir sicher dass
ich hier auf jeden fall gut deal gut
viel gemacht habe aber bevor ich es
vergesse ich habe ja im netz mir nur
gesagt im vorletzten video immer wenn
ich jetzt einen guten deal machte dann
sage ich will hier so eingeblendet good
feel good feel und ja ich würde sagen
wir sind noch nicht am ende alter was
ist das denn monitor hort table monitor
von wimax das ist glaube ich das erste
mal dass sich ein computerbildschirm im
video habt es ist ein kleiner bildschirm
aber es ist ein
bildschirm ohne also es ist wirklich
wortwörtlich nur der bildschirm vom
bildschirm vielen dank dafür danke dann
haben wir hier noch sachen wie dieses
ding von blaupunkt fast vielleicht 25
euro baumholder oder auch eine hanna
decker was für hama sechs button aus
dies noch komplett neu eingepackt wir
sind auch jetzt total im trend diese
mäuschen das hier ist vielleicht das
letzte paket was ich noch auf machen
könnte und der rest ist halt wirklich
jetzt nichts besonderes mehr haben noch
irgendwelche
druckerpatronen und hier noch ein
telefon aber das war es dann auch wo ist
jetzt mein messer und wissen dass a das
klingt auch nicht gut also das ganze im
pc verbauen also leute kleines fazit ich
bin mir fast sicher dass ich hier auf
jeden fall über 550 euro rausholen
könnte wenn ich alles einzeln verkaufen
können schon sein natürlich wird auch
vielleicht das ein oder andere nicht
funktionieren somit war das eigentlich
ganz cool also märz auf jeden fall spaß
gemacht dass auszupacken wann cooles
paket bin mal gespannt von welchem
discounter von welchem laden wir als
nächstes retour mit stern ich will das
jetzt immer so ein bisschen staffeln
dass ich mir einen namen rauspicken
anschaue von denen irgendwie retouren zu
bekommen leute danke fürs zuschauen wir
sehen uns nächste woche wieder gibt es
ein neues lied und anderes video danke
zuschauern bei drei turnieren nicht
vergessen